Mất lương tối thử tháng theo bồn vùng vùng vùng vùng vùng một lãn nắm phía bài trợ đầm một tháng, vùng 2 là nắm phía không tạm chử đầm một tháng.
Vùng 3 là 4 phải 4 là 4 tháng, vùng 4 là 4 phải không vốn trợ đầm một tháng.
Mình lương tối thử nương trên tăng từ 8,000 người nghiệp đến 8,000 chi Minh Nhìn Đồng,
tương hương biết tỷ lệ bình quan bài phía tạm vành trăm sòng với mất lương tối thử giải thành.
Mình điều chính lượng tối thử nếu trên cao hơn khoảng 8,000 một phần chăm,
sòng với mức sòng tối thử của người lâu động.
Đến hết năm hành hình không chăm hà mi bài để cai thiện trong người lâu động.
Bình được vụ nếu xóo mất điều chính này sẽ có sự chiếc sản,
2 hoa lựa ý cổ người lâu động và sân nghiệp,
vừa chú ý cai thiện đôi sống trong người lâu động,
vừa chú ý đến việc bảo đam dưới chi và phát triển sản xuất thình sáng của sân nghiệp.
Về thời điểm để xói điều chính mới lương tối hiểu,
lưu thử kiện tương ngay một tháng 1, nắm hành hình không chăm hà mi bài.
Theo bộ nơi vụ để bảo đam thời sân cho sân nghiệp trình bị phương án, môn lực thực hiện.
Một nội dung khác, tương thảo quy định các mơ lương tối thiểu dờ theo bốn phòng.
Theo đỏ vùng 1 là 2 bẩy yên bốn chăm đồng dờ.
Vùng 2 là 2 mươi 1,5 đồng dờ.
Vùng 3 là 2 nấu thịt bốn chăm đồng dờ.
Vùng 1 là 1 chính yên bốn chăm đồng dờ.
Các quan sận thảo cho 2, bất lương tối thiểu dờ tiếp tục được xa định dựa trên phương pháp quy đổi.
Tương đường từ mức lần tối thiểu kháng.
Và thời gian làm việc yêu chuẩn thật quy định của bộ lật sau đó.
Đây là phương pháp được tương thầy lửa đả quyến nghiệp Việt Nam lựa trọn và sự giống khi tính mừng lương tối thiểu dờ.
Tương năm 2018, đến này.